Zain its wait don't hang up I just want
to wish you a very happy birthday again
I also want to apologize for jumping out
of the cake like that I didn't realize
was the middle of the night I had no
idea was in the middle of your bedroom
I want to thank your security who were
very very gentle and creative with the
Taser
so anyway happy birthday to you and mr.
Tim Horton you share your birthday with
a very special Canadian who's very near
and dear to my heart all right
hey everybody big surprise Ryan Reynolds
has started the promotional tour
Early's the viral tour leading up to
some big Deadpool footage that they'll
probably drop around the Superbowl
didn't know that he was that much of a
Zayn Malik fan but he has been known to
pop out of cakes if you're wondering
what the Tim Hortons shout-out was about
that's because Deadpool is Canadian Ryan
Reynolds his Canadians so they've always
making lots of Canada jokes in Tim
Hortons is just one of the most popular
big food chains but if you guys didn't
know they just changed the release date
of the film I wasn't intending on making
a video but then they dropped this it
was like okay perfect opportunity and we
can talk about why they moved the New
Mutants movie which was coming out in
April but if you're finding me for the
first time obviously you've seen from
all the infinity war and Black Panthers
been dropping there's only gonna be even
more cool stuff coming so be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos but
what's happening is is Deadpool is now
coming two weeks sooner on May 18th so
it used to be coming out the first week
in June now you get to see it two weeks
earlier
so everybody shout with joy but a lot of
it has to do with this domino effect
with the gambit movie so really the
problem is with the gambit movie and
it's not as big of a problem as people
think because it's like the movie that's
never going to get here there's always
delays they announce a director he has
to leave because of scheduling issues
the latest series of events that all led
to Deadpool being bumped up started with
Gore Verbinski who's the director on the
channing tatum gambit movie he left they
said it was because of scheduling issues
but then later The Hollywood Reporter
said that it was because of a tonal
change in the film originally I think
the idea was to push for an r-rating it
was going to be a heist film set in New
Orleans and it was gonna flow more like
a straight-up action film just a really
hardcore
version of a gambit movie but then The
Hollywood Reporter said that they wanted
to change the tone of the film to a more
hard are comedic film like Deadpool was
so that just required a different
director because that's not the movie
that Gore Verbinski's signed on to
direct usually that's what happens when
a director in the studio disagree on the
direction of film should take like when
you heard about Tim Miller leaving the
Deadpool film they just had completely
different ideas about what the sequel
should be writers have been working on
the script we already talked about who's
who's gonna be in character so the
writers have been working on script and
that's it I just started some
preliminary design but so Tim Miller
left he signed on to that Terminator
project that James Cameron's trying to
do they also just announced that he's
gonna do a kitty pryde shadow cat movie
- who knows that that'll ever get made
but that's kind of a separate issue Gore
Verbinski had been doing a lot of
pre-production he left the movie and
they're supposed to start shooting March
19th of this year released the movie
next year so when you lose your director
right before you're getting ready to
shoot it causes a bit of a scramble so
they might bump that date a little bit
but also while this was happening the
New Mutants movie that was originally
going to be coming out this April it was
gonna be more of a smaller horror flick
with the original New Mutants to line up
even though Deadpool did debut in the
New Mutants comic book I don't think
that he was going to appear in that
movie in any way but based on the
success of things like stranger things
and movies like it the studio decided to
turn it into more of a legit horror
flick and just lean in to the horror
elements so they bumped the movie ten
months it's now February 2019 and that
will give them the time they need to
reshoot whatever scenes they need to do
to make it a scarier film so when I say
that I don't know if the studio intends
on turning it from more of a pg-13 movie
into an arm movie like really going for
horror its style but I think they just
sense the demand for that type of film
so they're like okay you know people are
wanting to see new mutants but they're
not banging down the door to see it so
it's okay if we bump that and we'll just
give them Deadpool a little bit sooner
to placate them so
I kind of think that's why they bumped
Deadpool up because they sense that it's
really strong it's a movie that people
are really looking forward to and they
had to shuffle all these other movies so
the like how do we make people happy
we'll give them some of that sweet
Deadpool juice just a little bit sooner
than we were originally intending to
what you think is a smart move on their
part and I think in addition to that
they're gonna bump up their marketing
campaign which doesn't guarantee that
we're gonna get a Super Bowl trailer but
if they're starting to do things like
this like Ryan Reynolds is slowly
popping up in people's Instagram feeds
and little weird places that means their
viral campaign has started then they'll
do more legit advertising as we get
closer so you remember the 12 days of
Deadpool you remember all those funny
promos that he did this message is
brought to you by Deadpool gentlemen How
well do you know your happy sack I'm
sure you rummage around downstairs more
than mommy would like but it's time you
started paying attention to your
favorite pastime because that bag of
beans bouncing around in your hand could
be trying to kill you what yeah because
testicular cancer is the most common
form of cancer in men aged between 15
and 35 the find really weird odd things
and places for him to pop up that you
wouldn't necessarily expect like
Avengers infinity war is coming out at
the beginning of May now we have
Deadpool coming out in the middle of May
then at the end is supposed to be Star
Wars han Solo and I don't think the
Deadpool has to worry about Han Solo at
all like people will go see a Star Wars
movie because it says Star Wars even if
it's not the greatest movie ever
Deadpool may not crush Star Wars because
it's Star Wars and it's so popular
internationally but Deadpool is such a
bang out hit that I think that it'll do
just fine the only downside is that it
might affect infinity Wars chances of
topping the box-office from the first
Avengers film but I don't know if that's
gonna happen I think they'll get close
but remember the first Avengers movie
back in 2012 did about 1.5 billion
worldwide so I think infinity war does
minimum billion billion - Captain
America Civil War was 1.1 so II don't
think that infinity ward's gonna have
any problems cracking that
billion-dollar number the question is is
will it reach 2 billion dollars because
people really like Marvel movies but in
order to reach that kind of Star Wars
The Force awakens number
you have to have the entire world going
back to see the movie multiple times in
the theater it's not enough to just see
the movie once that gets you to that
first billion the second billion is
driven by everybody going to see it a
second a third a fourth time so we'll
just we'll see how that's affected by
Deadpool in Star Wars coming out so
quickly right after that but for those
of you asking we will totally get a new
Deadpool trailer relatively soon like
there'll be a new infinity war promo
pretty soon obviously black panthers
coming out in a couple weeks
so most of Marvel's marketing is gonna
be based around that but then probably
some time before infinity war will see
that ant-man in the wasp trailer I've
started to get a lot of questions about
that so just leave all your questions in
the comments below and we'll find out
more about which superbowl trailers are
gonna drop in the next week or two they
usually wait till the last minute to
announce that kind of stuff but if you
didn't see it I just posted a new
infinity war promo you can click here to
watch that and learn about the
time-travel theory it's not quite what
you think and you can click here to
rewatch the Deadpool trailer and learn
all about the villains thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]